objectif 90% le 'rafale' lors d'une
allocution depuis la maison blanche
lundi
joe biden s'est montré pour le moins
optimiste 90% ces lotos d'américains qui
seront selon lui éligibles à la
vaccination d'ici le 19 avril prochain
soit dans trois semaines seulement
durant les trois derniers jours nous
avons administré un nombre record
d'injection avec plus de 10 millions
d'injections pendant le week end
plus de 10 millions d'injections trois
jours cela aurait été inconcevable en
janvier et ce n'est pas tout 90 % sera
aussi selon lui le pourcentage de
citoyens américains qui auront accès à
un centre de vaccination à moins de 8
kilomètres de leur domicile dont le même
ton le président américain a lancé une
mise en garde en affirmant que la guerre
contre locaux vides 19 est loin d'être
gagné le programme de vaccination
pourrait encore faire face à un revers
et surtout si nous baissons la gare
maintenant le gie riches pourraient
empirer
non pas s'améliorer une intensification
de la campagne de vaccination pour le
moins ambitieuse alors que la pandémie
fait toujours près de mille morts par
jour aux états unis et que depuis une
semaine
soixante mille nouveaux cas quotidiens
sont confirmés mais cette vaccination
massive serait selon les autorités
rendu possible par l'augmentation des
livraisons de flacons de vaccin dans le
pays et par la multiplication des
centres de vaccination ainsi que par
l'augmentation du nombre de pharmacies
autorisé à procéder aux injections
depuis lundi déjà certains états comme
l'ohio le texas ont élargi les gie
milité au vaccin à tous les adultes de
plus de 16 ans un soulagement pour les
personnes qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner
je me sens quelque sorte soulagé et
c'est en quelque sorte excitant parce
que c'est comme si on arrivait enfin à
la fin de toute cette folle période
maintenant que nous nous faisons tous
vaccinés
c'est comme si on arrivait à la fin de
tout ça et c'est bien je suis très
heureuse que nous puissions accueillir
tout le monde
c'est difficile lorsque l'on doit
refuser des personnes en raison de
certaines circonstances
donc cela nous permet de pouvoir
atteindre toutes les personnes possibles
qui veulent recevoir ce vaccin contre le
coc vide 19 lundi joe biden a aussi
appelé des gouverneurs et des mères qui
avait levé l'obligation du port du
masque dans leurs états à faire machine
arrière en évoquant un devoir
patriotique